era tutti ragazzi e prendete questo lo
vidi sono fari j
oggi siamo in un nuovo video serale e
questo è il secondo video della giornata
per quanto possa essere strano in via
quando faccio video di saper che nessuno
se lo aspetta
ricordati che io faccio video anche
mentre stai dormendo mentre ti osservo
da quanto era da maniaco questa sì come
avete fatto notare alimenti a tutti che
quel geniaccio il ruolo più il bravo
ragazzo mi ha sfidato per la sfida del
choco marche per in tribuna cosa come il
draw mylife chabib anni diciamo
installando tantissimi questo periodo
grazie per avermi nominato per questa
cosa fa poi ti ringrazierà dovere
siciliani che basta da è dentro
ecco i ragazzi ci sono le istruzioni
fare per la sfida che mette altro già
con la scritta challenge mismi spingerà
come foto di ragazzi ancora aperto
perché dovrei essere impreparato pasta
sfida non deve sapere cosa sto andando a
fare prima di prima di farlo perchè è
giusto così
però ragazzi voi vi ricordate vi una
cosa qualsiasi cosa ma si sa si cosa io
io debba fare adesso
ricordatevi c'è più ha voluto bene
perché lo fa vi quest'estate chiunque
può partecipare allacciato vercelli per
vincere esperienza della nannini che noi
l'abbiamo pensata una soltanto per terra
sei pronto
in teoria no però vabbè abbiamo chiuso a
chiave delizioso ciò che crede la chiave
che lo avrei in fondo una piscina per
bambini prendi il tuo costume da bagno
inizia la sua caccia al gioco eredi in
bocca al lupo fa vi state prendendo
bridge mentre in una piscina per bambini
con questo è trovare la chiave
io ve l'avevo detto che sarebbe stato
tragico assente tipo la gente in costume
normale che va in giro in spiaggia ecco
perfetto ho deciso di non usare il
costume va di mettere un qualcosa di
alternativo tipo il mio pigiama perché
ho ragazzi veramente ma che schifo che
ho vomitato nel tutta roba pilot trovare
delle chiavi e una piscina e poi devo
aprire uno scrigno affrontassimo se
qualcuno poi per caso ritrova la mia
dignità da qualche parte da fa per
favore me lo dica grazie
[Musica]
questo bordello ma vogliamo riempire la
loro disco a casa ok faccetta nera
mantechiamo ci sono ragazzi sono tipo
qualcosa come 100 chiamate e credo che
un omissis e anche infilata nel deretano
fantastico e allora non era questa da
questi casi o leggermente freddo ma se
non il suo capisco mi sentiva già
capitale
[Musica]
dio ama slime l'asciugamano ma facciamo
due d'accordo ragazzi dopo tutto il
casino che è successo per i venti
ragazze di scattare il gioco club a un
numero unico che si mette del suo sito
goal.com che vi lascio comunque in
descrizione potreste comunque essere
estratti per vincerlo nell esperienza 3
nalini che vi sono casi non gli scooter
e potete fare ragazzi con il salto con
la corda elastica ce ne sono un caso che
maleducato ne parlo con la bocca piena
su da acu che potete vincere un casino
lista sfide che sono tutte comunque meno
bagnatele la mia questo questo è sicuro
e direi che è giunto il momento della
nomination fino a 9 perché i momenti qui
nomino io le persone mi sento tipo col
potere in mano o la vita di una persona
in mano in questo momento tutto non so
chi non vince mai h ammette ragazzi
scusate ma mi dispiace ma dai ragazzi
servito da piaciuto non mi alzo che
faccio un lago di garda se il video è
piaciuto come al solito show ad un
commento mi piace anche la passione di
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione se non sapessi di scheletri
non ci vendiamo il prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]